okay so we'll do more energy work again
the reason why is you're not doing the
Bedrock
practices we do energy work when we do
Kona
but if you don't do the Bedrock
practices what is a contest will remain
a contest you won't non- contest okay so
we'll do some energy work
and we have to do the energy work so you
guys understand you can't cut to the end
okay because you're not doing the
Bedrock practices
so some of the things like the
disciplines you're not doing
them they have an impact on
you and
then you have all those other practices
and particularly the ones that were
designed to create some distance from
your worldly
attachment you're still being sucked by
the world you still Place way too much
importance on your
career and everything else that goes
with it and so when you show up here at
the end of the day you're just a wreck
by our standards by the world standards
you're doing good but by our standards
which are not the world standards you're
not doing well you're not well okay so
we'll
do some movement you're going to have to
do more movement okay so we'll start
with the shman suby which is an
energetic
drill but it doesn't require as much
sensitivity it doesn't require as
much of you to fix your Bedrock
practices
okay but let me give you some things
okay
remember you're supposed to be
midfoot and you're supposed to
continually scan for
tension and you're supposed to
desire so while you're tasked with
cutting you should not be trying to
cut while you're task with picking up
the sword you should not be trying to
pick up the sword while your task with
putting down the sword you should not be
trying to put down the
St as you're getting tired it's probably
going to show up in some sort of
cramp that's how you would describe it
but that cramp is tension Let It
Go cramp's Pain do not exist if you let
it
go so I'm midfoot I'm scanning for
tension I'm releasing the desire my
teacher gave me a raiseed The Sword
without trying to to raise the sword
drop the sword without trying to drop
the sword I keep reflecting on
that go
ahead some other things I'm seeking
centeredness which means Stillness no
movement my mind should not move when my
mind moves it's dichotomous if it's
dichotomous I'm in the ego tripartite
mind so don't move your body any more
than your
TOS watch your hands opening and closing
and your fingers doing different things
touch that's
it in without lifting down without
pushing
down scanning for
tension harmonizing with the
Suka
okay let's get there and I'll add more
go
release your
jaw neck throat tension release it
release
it don't lift the sword if I don't lift
the sword my elbows and my wrist won't
change
angles my hands float load up my hands
drop midfoot not heel
midfoot midfoot not
heal but my heels are on the ground I
don't artificially Le lift them
up
jaw and neck shoulder tension
releasing lower leg tension
releasing my heels are touching the
ground my heels don't bounce off the
ground you're too far forward on your
feet Yes Sensei no resistance no
contention especially from the
teacher so the sword's not done Rising
you're pulling it down so that would be
trying
to cut down don't try to cut
down go and change your
grip hands float up hands descend
gravity pulls my
hands
so my metatarsals should spread out if
I'm doing this right not
curl my metatarsal should
spread you're back to pulling it
down
their feet are back to
curling shoulder
tension your shoulders drop the shoulder
blades
drop too much shoulder tension you're
rounding your
back you're trying to
cut you're trying to have Center Line po
you're pulling in everything just
rounding your
back hands float
up way too much tension in the upper
body from the solar plexus
up and if I if my toes are out then I'm
going to obviously be be heal weighted
so my middle toe is straight straight
straight
straight you see how much in that feels
to you yes okay because you're doing
this all the time
okay shoulder
tension you're pursing your
lips this is all tension it's it's all
normalized and you don't recognize it
anymore as
tension all
right you have to keep working on those
things and again don't forget the first
practice that you worked on is more your
worldly attachment you have to work on
it to in the world way to in the
world like you want me to be a nun yes
yes I do that's what I
want you made a bond with
me that was the
bond I'm doing my part you're not doing
your
part but you still want my
part this
crowd this
part here not the top not what we now
think is the top that's not the
top I don't want my chin
up I don't want my tongue to roll
back if you put your chin
up and you put your tongue
forward you're going to feel tension try
it right now you're you're you're like a
good modern ioka you see you guys see it
now push your
tongue on the back of the top
teeth and you feel there's tongue
tension you feel that okay know you have
to that's not the top that's not where
it
goes so I have to put
the crowd of my head at the top higher
than this I this
has to go lower than this do you see
okay have a how it doesn't do it by
crunching my neck
forward because what you really want in
in you're doing that is that the mass of
your head gets on your
spine becomes part of your
spine but you're also going to be
able to turn the ears
out of the dichotomous mind right now
your senses your five senses they they
see things well they see things because
they discriminate they discriminate
because they're
dichotomous so what you want to do is if
you take a certain posture with your
body in the
beginning just as you can take tension
away from your tongue with a certain
angle it could do something to the
inside of my ears
that help
me so what I'm going to do is my chin
kind of goes
back what I do now is when I feel it I
feel it in my ears I feel it in my ear I
feel the feeling in my ears everything
you hear gets kind of
muted but I will give you physical
reference points but you're looking for
a muting got
it so you have your
head and rather than make your temple go
forward as you would if you just kind of
lean your head
forward you're going to keep your temple
still and you're going to rotate around
that I keep my temple here in space and
I make my chin rotate around that and
after a while you'll feel oh yeah I feel
kind of muted like not quite like
someone did that to you
but it's of that sense
okay so now you add that
boom you see how my chin stays there
doesn't
go or
here
okay then
inside keep your throat open
this exercise is too
quick so your throat's
open open this area as we've mentioned
in other
trainings the air is going to go
in and on the
drop on the hand descending and the
sword going down and your arms going
down it'll exhale we're not going to
force it today we have those breathing
practices but this one I just keep this
throat
open and I'm letting what my body is
doing inhale and exhale so in other
words I'm KN here going which we've done
this one open I'm trying to let go of
the
World open stays
open I don't breathe in other
words
[Music]
got it your breath is going to be pretty
short because the movement is so quick
you got it and you're probably going to
feel like you're suffocating but that's
the fear because your
body and your urge to keep the body
alive is part of your worldly attachment
but you're getting enough
air okay okay got it so I don't inhale
once and I don't exhale once I just keep
this throat this this throat chakra open
and it does it okay all right if you
can but if you can't you're doing the
first set of instruction okay all right
here we go all right
so remember that the ego triart type
mind God mine division is like
a
expedited
summary of Silk Road technology
itself it's meant to accommodate the
modern
user the modern user isn't ready for a
supernatural
world but there's been plenty of many
times when I tell
you that there's a
cosmological framework for all of
this and
movement especially movement with
intention is not of the god
mind
you're even as we were doing that drill
we were seeking ways
of taking out intention do you see that
so I'm breathing without breathing no my
there's air going in and out of my lungs
keeping me alive but I don't try to
inhale nor
exhale the sword is going up and down
but I'm not trying to lift it nor trying
to get it down you see that I'm midfoot
weight not by trying to keep my weight
off my heels you see that I just do
nothing and then my metatarsal spread
but all movement is is a kind of
manipulation it's a it's a human
manipulation of that one part of the
cosmos which is not of
movement so remember that when we did
these drills I complained that you can't
do the other work do you see we need to
do this kind of human manipulation but
all human manipulations are not
it so when we do our C and our IE drill
sets the first one is stillness but the
last one is stillness
too so here we are we start you're in
[Music]
Sea you're going to get
yourself in exactly what I just said
okay only we're not
moving so I am not trying to sit
upright you see I I
just
nothing find where everything just
stacks on
itself remember this has to stack if I
go like this and I stop tensing all my
tension guess what's going to happen
eventually cuz watch I'm starting to
feel it in my throat because I'm going
to fall backwards so I have to hold
myself up here and now there's tension
in my throat and now I have to
breathe with intention my throat will
not open and do it on its
own so remember I got to get the crown
of the head on top of the spine and I
have to pull back
and I can use this kinesthetic
index but it won't do you any good if
you don't feel that in your
ears and the same will go for where your
tongue goes goes on the top of the mouth
towards the
front put that tip of your
tongue on your pallet right behind your
front two te
don't press on your teeth that's
tension you should have like a little
bump there you feel that little bump
that's where it
goes then your eyes are going
to you're you're not going to use your
eyes so your eyes are going to
fall if you pay attention when you go
here it's going to take muscle to close
them all the way so bring your gaze to a
45 angle downward just to get you in
the area or think about the angle of
your nose do you see this
angle that's where my gaze goes I'm not
looking at my nose but I take away the
lifting and the tempting to see the
seeing of the Gaze I take away the
agency of the Gaze the intention of the
Gaze boom and it'll go to this angle
once you get there watch I want you to
get there and then I want you to close
your eyes and you're going to see it
took muscle to close my eyes try
it you feel that little flexion it took
right we don't want that flexion okay so
to not see I have to try I cannot try to
not
see that's the same problem so I don't
shut my
eyes okay
so everything I don't care what you do
with your arms right now for now but
don't do anything that's going to mess
up the spine and the head and the throat
alignment
okay so just let them touch here let
your elbows fall let your shoulders
fall once you get there same
thing open the throat
and you letting the body inhale let's
get that at least it's going to be hard
for you to let it
exhale open the throat and the body is
going to
fill so way of knowing
I don't want to just film me doing it
there's not much to see here okay you
can't be in the way of the camera and
you're going to sit down you're going to
put a hand on my
shoulder and a
hand on my
abdomen okay now when I have the
intention of
inhaling you feel that when I just open
the
throat
do you feel that do you feel this do you
see that and that's abdominal breathing
okay it's not
me trying to breathe into my stomach
it's what happens from me not
breathing and from me just opening and
the air will go in okay so let's break
this up because you have to do something
else to get the exhale to be
unintentional okay so what I want you to
do is your elbows are
down your shoulders are down and I want
you to put them on the earth contact
point so if you were standing that would
be your midfoot so get yourself in
position and feel where when everything
is resting where do I
feel the ground pressure got it and once
you do that put your hands on your legs
and and now put your shoulders on your
elbows into that ground
pressure fix your chin and
Crown release the throat
chakra it's going to come in faster than
you are used
to and then do another rep of
that still have to release
tension your shoulders should drop when
you put the shoulder mass and the and
the elbow Mass on the ground the Earth
contact
Point remember not to turn your head and
just drop your chin you have to turn
around your temple your Chin's to
downward
in and all throat tension is is gone
shoulder tension is
gone your eyes are too open cast them
down at the angle of your
nose to someone looking straight on from
you your eyes will look closed that ears
are too up too up too high more cast
your gaze down more towards the
kn
okay look I'm going to give you some
confirmatory elements so if I put my
elbows out you see
that you see
that and my deltoid is activated and the
weight's in my hands don't want
that my elbows will come down naturally
you see
no they won't be like this come down
naturally my shoulder blades I'm going
to exaggerate it now my shoulder blades
are going to drop they're going to
drop my elbows are going to come
slightly forward and then when my elbows
Dro they're going to come in towards my
rib cage they can't be out okay so make
sure your elbows are down here not out
like this all right try it again okay so
the the first first if you're at that
first
level I just want you to let this open
open and here's your con conf
confirmatory aspect shoulders don't go
up Alin swells okay on the next
level you're going to give me your
hand okay this is going to feel you're
going to you got to be light to the
touch so you
don't your tension doesn't change your
sensitivity there very light to the
touch okay so uh you're going to feel a
swelling when I open the
throat and then you my stomach won't go
in and out on either the exhale or the
inhale you will feel things moving but
you won't feel
this got it you see how it goes in and
out okay so the first one you'll feel
feel
swell
you notice that now okay so when you do
your abdominal breathing yes here not
here but not
here do you understand
okay
so as you're working more
advanced in English this is called
reverse breathing but it's not going in
and
out it's bad it's a bad description do
you understand okay so what I'm doing is
the throat is going to
open got it it's it's kind of startling
at how what
happens because your Consciousness is
changing and just like a baby when
they're going to sleep they feel their
Consciousness changing they they'll
tense okay so now you're breathing
without breathing it's startling and
your Consciousness is going to want to
change that's why you're doing it you're
going You're trying to move from your
ego tripartite mind to its sensation to
what I call the god
mine so as you
inhale your
body it's going
to it's going to want to hold because
it's dying
really spiritually it's dying do you get
it it's going to seize so as you feel
this you
release and you're looking for this
upper lumbar
region it's a it's a skill okay it's not
it's not a
it's not an idea it's a coordination
there's a coordination to it you're
going to release you're going to be
sensitive enough again it's a higher
skill you're going to be sensitive
enough to feel that seizure and then
you're going to release it and then
you're going to go whoa and it's going
to really fill
okay and when it
[Music]
fills I want your mind to accept the
death of the
body do a death
meditation and as you're doing a death
meditation see if you if you can try it
put your fingers
here feel what it's doing you're
Dy there's no point to anything more
tomorrow is
gone is you get to rest
now nothing
matters it was all a
dream and as you're doing
that you feel the sword of the
Executioner on your
neck on your
inhale it want you to
feel that there's a kind
of stomach going in on the inhale from
the inside though not me sucking it
in not me pulling it in no real great
flexion just release to
death
and if you can get that
sense notice then on the exhale if you
truly let go of all the
body the stomach
now also will
draw when you empty the lungs of hair of
air this part still
drops and so it expands on the exhale
and and so as I'm doing this there's a
pulling in on the
inhale and there's a falling out on the
exhale and my stomach doesn't move which
is what you felt doesn't go in and
out that that is technically what is
reverse breathing but it's not me having
my ego tripartite mind trying to do it
okay so
release
death
meditation on the
inhale when you release this you'll
feel almost it's going the other way on
the inhale do you get it that is what
stops it from
going you see got it okay then on the
exhale keep it
released and then it will fall and so so
it stays
open do you understand okay some
confirmatory things and you have to be
careful
okay especially if you're if you're
forcing it by reverse breathing like
like modern being it so they're going to
open and they're pulling in the stomach
you're going to get a lot of blood
pressure change going up this way okay
but even without it you will feel a
pressure izing of your body going up
something like that okay got it but
don't try to feel it don't intend to
feel it don't want to feel it you do the
things your teacher said to do okay try
it what happens as you do this is your
Consciousness change so you're the way
you're experiencing your moment right
here on this mat it changes okay that
change is that ego tripartite mind
coming to a stop it's going to feel a
certain
way that's what you're after you're not
after a stomach that doesn't go in and
out who gives a you're not after
say that you're not after letting go of
my worldly attachment I'm I'm not after
that I'm after the feeling of the ego
tripartite mind coming to a stop so that
instantaneously I can be in
it and it's irrelevant of posture or
anything else and this is what I
want my drills that I do are to give me
agency in entering the god
mind
when within what environment it's a
skill Awakening is a skill Awakening is
the gaining
Agency on bringing a sensation to the
ego tripartite
mind
so as I have that
feeling I'm now going to do a
confirmatory exercise that I have the
feeling so he's going to push and I
don't try to not fall over because now
I'm activating my ego tripartite mind I
don't try to hold my arm still
I stay in the feeling of the change in
Consciousness I can use my kinesthetic
index points Temple
chin I can't use the feeling of the
energetics but I'm more
interested in the feeling in the change
of
Consciousness because nothing Alters
once I understand the feeling and the
change of Consciousness I don't need the
energetics I don't need the the little
exercises I don't need
[Music]
them I don't need
them and don't need
them they just get me in the ball
part okay so when we do exercise
two whether it's
katate you have to try to keep the
feeling that you were gaining from
exercise one don't now bring all your
intention in here try to keep his arm
there try to not fall over bring this
same exact stuff you were doing just
like you were
meditating got it there's I don't need
to have my hands here do you understand
to to shut the god M do you understand
so I don't have to have my chin here I
don't have to have sesa I don't have to
have any of that stuff but at the same
time it doesn't matter that I'm in those
things okay so I keep the same feeling
and I am trying to make my feeling of
drill Dr two feel exactly like drill one
doesn't matter what he's
doing in drill one I did have
mass being pulled down by gravity do you
understand so here I have energy
gravity's energy Mass traveling by
gravity energy here's energy it doesn't
matter I just do drill
one
in the same way I would have let go of
grip tension or cramping flexion I let
go of this anything that I'm feeling I
let go of
it I let go that there's one hand up and
one hand down that's not important the
god M doesn't feel those
things my there's no
tension so I can keep that shape I don't
have to go like
this I'm not looking for any kind of
Advantage not trying to do
anything I just go
into that
consciousness if I do you're going to
feel that upward pressure up going up to
spine in the head goes W and you're
going to know that oh yeah this is human
manipulation you got it if you can't do
it you're just going to feel it in your
shoulder Etc do you understand so what I
mean by human manipulation is you're
humanly artificially in my opinion
manipulating the cheat movement in your
body do do you get get it yeah
because I'm adding energy to it do you
see I this like it's like uh I'm giving
the the the cheese cycle an adrenaline
shot you get it I'm artificially trying
to amplify it that's what this is okay
it's a good thing to do and you need to
do it but it's not the gate or the
destination the gate or the destination
is the Stillness RS do you understand
that
okay so these are confirmatory and what
I mean by that is it's going to tell me
if I could enter that Consciousness or
not okay got and it there there the set
is all get me in the
door because as you saw I shouldn't need
the
set do you get it
okay so not to remember the C the I sets
are that they're expedited they're
expedited mean they're short cut so to
speak it's like you got to be able to do
this it's a bare minimum
okay but they're meant to expedite your
progress in them you have to keep in
mind all the other stuff so don't make a
fetish out of the drill I just showed
you the point is to not need the drill
the point is to not need the movement to
not need the posture do you understand
okay
so oh I'm going to do EO for example I
don't try to do EO I don't try to make
his arm move I try to just enter into
the conscious state that I want my hand
is just the way that my the sword my
hand went up the sword went up the sword
came down I didn't make it go so the
same thing as I'm moving my hand is just
loose very relaxed you see that my hand
is
relaxed
but it's not wimpy where I'm going do
you understand okay so my my hand is I'm
going to leave my my hand more like this
so you can see okay or just like I lift
the sword okay don't intend to lift my
sword but I'm moving just like drill one
my but my hand is relaxed so just like
he could he can't push me and drill one
he can't push me either here you see
because remember there's no there was no
need for the form so he's he can't move
me anywhere in the cycle okay got it so
I as I come around to do it my hand is
relaxed but it's not just him okay so
for
example um Margaret you can come you're
going to push me at that
angle get on the shoulder you're going
to push me okay so push there you go
and he's
pushing and nope I just go into the
state and we're they're not going to be
able to move
me push push got it okay I'm just
relaxed I'm in the
state
so if she's pushing same thing it would
be by myself you come project you
see doesn't matter that there's two
different vectors here doesn't matter
I'm in that
state got it so that would be another
confirmatory confirmatory exercise if
I'm doing it right if I'm not
bracing I can be at multiple
angles do you got it
okay just for in Google right again
as I'm moving you're going to do your
inward your inward
spiral right got it okay okay so uh same
thing is I I don't can't have that
collapsible do you understand CU I I am
using the energy I'm
artificially manipulating the ches cycle
that's what I'm doing here okay it's
human intervention I come
in
move so it any angle that I take as I
just you just saw like it doesn't make
sense for example
she's pushing into him do you understand
cuz it's like yeah that's not it that's
that's why you go on the CR you go on
the cross you go on the cross okay got
it so but I want to pay attention to
this okay so he's got his spinal
displacement right he's got that I want
you to pay attention that it doesn't go
off remember I did the little goofy
thing
this part's goofy you see okay but I
have to bring yourself
in but if he were to change
it it's stuck it's not going anywhere
without the
tension you get do you
understand my hand is still just without
intention moving through
space where my training is this is in
that state of
consciousness
try that feeling should be the same as
drill one
go you feel your desire to grab her hand
there's no desire her hand's just
there you can see your mind come back
you could see your ego mind come back to
grab the
hand just the
feeling now you desired or not grab the
hand there is a pattern that you have to
follow the pattern is coordinated
towards this Consciousness if you change
the pattern from the one your teacher
gave you you're going to change the
Consciousness that's being sought
through the pattern got it so that your
your hand the way you get that hand is
not the way your teacher taught you you
and because of the
concentricity
between the martial component and the
energetic component and the spiritual
component while it's not spiritual it's
also not Marshall you cannot grab a hand
like that of somebody who is resisting
you okay so you have to do the pattern
the way your teacher told you okay try
it again so if my Marshall
my arm is going to be in the fight it's
not going to be out of the
fight and I won't do one
movement wait and then do another
movement if I am in the state of
consciousness of drill one my entire
body is in it so I don't have an arm
that's dead and waiting everything is
moving okay so just like or everything's
involved let's put it that way just like
if Margaret came and pushed at this
angle I'm not going anywhere do you see
I don't have to go oh someone's pushing
on me okay I'm already in the state
you're
pushing and so both sides are involved
both sides are moving in harmony with
each other you see this hands on my
center line which is where it would be
in a
fight always bring it into the
Trap see take one more
turn in the
fight pay attention if I grab your hand
or your hand falls into my
ground you should have
known what's it doing it's falling it's
falling into the ground you think came
off on its
own when does my left hand actually
close at the
bottom
okay
[Music]
go I'll let you pass
go see you got to get you got to disarm
it with this arm not with this
arm pull it off with the other hand pull
it off I mean it do it you better get it
off you see how much it takes what do
you think is going to happen in that
time uh you can count I'm going to punch
you in the face and knock you the F out
so you have to go one just have it ready
move disarm with this arm just
wait go there it
is got
it there's no desire to grab the hand
the hand just is
there okay so I'm more interested in my
Consciousness but I have the
confirmatory aspects of it so I all the
other stuff that you I could tell you
about you still supposed to have them in
there okay a swelling no lifting an
opening
releasing right uh
nonattachment kind of reverse breathing
but in air Cod is not what everyone
means okay what I said it means got it
all that should still be there right
you're you're your alignment in his Yang
energy and my yang energy is on the
Earth's contact Point all that's exactly
the same you understand so you you can't
be out
here no the fact that he could push me
over is confirmatory which means you
were not actually
in the sensation of the ego tripartite
mind do you got it and so it's not about
necess it's not about going fast or
anything
it's just about feeling that feeling
what feeling the correct number one
feeling the correct drill number one
feeling that feeling and now move with
that feeling okay got it but as I said
all this is human
intervention
Kona is a human manipulation of these
cosmological principles they are a lower
level than level than drill one got it
okay
okay but so what you're trying to do
here is
[Music]
manipulate that energetic those
energetic aspects which we already know
by those confirmatory
aspects that they alter my
Consciousness okay but we're going to
manipulate them even more we're going to
manipulate them so that they spiry will
rotate and the way you do that is with
your hands so it's very important that
you don't try to make your hands with an
activation of that ego tripartite line
but I have to keep the powder because
the pattern is going to spiral
rotate the alchemical aspects the
energetic aspects in that lower tonden
field got do you got that okay so I have
to make these shapes these shap these
spiral circular shapes I have to make
those shapes okay I can't be going in
and out those will not affect it okay so
if you watch my our patterns our
patterns are rotating you see they're
rotating we rotate again if you were
looking at us over from ahead you get it
if you had a camera up there you would
see this whole thing is rotating
you see it okay it's
important and if you wash my hands my
hands I won't move my body but my hands
are rotating you see do you get it
okay so there's no reverse and there's
no sharp
Corners okay you got it and I don't
breathe I just open and the body's going
to
breathe got got it I don't breathe just
like I didn't Breathe Here I will have
more
fill and more exhalation because the
movement's bigger do do you understand
okay but I don't breathe so watch for
that those
circles but every time if you can make
this like a ball in your mind but it's
out
here you see that I'm kind of spinning
the
ball do you see I spin the ball here's
the ball I'm on the back side I go under
I go to the top okay that's that inward
that's this part top of the ball the
ball's here top of the ball unders side
the ball back on the top on the inside
of the arm you see that
okay boom
boom here it is the ball take the whole
ball move it I'm going over the top top
of the ball boom down and in and that is
where everything settles like drill
one that's why I call iido pins K you
okay so I'm spinning this whole
thing and if if he if he wasn't there
you would see me to be spinning this
whole ball whole
ball got it you see that imagine there's
a ball
here you have to do the other side cuz
you always spun it one way you have to
do the other
side
come make it
small
big doesn't
matter but do you see the po I can only
do
this I can do it on the inside I can do
it on the outside can do it on the
reverse I can do it on the inverse those
are all your test
ofing so first let me context that
contextualize your question here by
remember that these
are if back to my cultural cultural
anthropology these are human
manipulation of cosmological principles
that that's what these are okay they're
not
self-defense is there a cuden and a hen
is there is there an oral tradition and
is there uh an ability for uh um aaya
life aspects on how you teach yes okay
so as I always say iido is not it's
kihon waza this is just the the main
state of it okay what is the main state
of it these are for lack of a better
word energetic rituals or alchemical
rituals that's all they are okay and
they're following cosmological
principles in short again an expedited
way is the structure of the ego
tripartite mind has one of its aspects
is dichotomy
okay and to to bring a sensation to the
ego tripartite mind which is what you're
trying to do you're not trying to keep
someone from pushing you over that's a
confirmatory element okay that's not
your
goal if I
can truly bring a sensation to the ego
tripartite
mind I am going to drop dichotomous
thinking dichotomous experience of the
world I'm it's going to go away
and what these Silk Road cultures have
figured
out is your dichotomy is like a force
this way and a force this way do you get
it the XY
axis and what you're going to do if you
spiral rotate them they can't manifest
in
dichotomy you spiral rotate them and
you're doing what R eliada noticed in
all these cultures this is a ritual of
eternal return so what he's saying and
which I totally agree with is you are
undoing
creation to go back to the time of
Genesis that pre that that spark do you
see where it happened and that is misi
is you purification yeah wash
yes but the ultimate Purity is prior to
existence by doing the eternal return
rituals okay so as we spiral rotate the
energetic alchemical aspects of our
being our ego tripartite mind starts to
spiry or rotate and as it starts to
spiral rotate it actually finds a
Stillness because it can't find a
dichotomy anymore do you see and now
it's
centered now God mind comes in this God
mind the conscious experience the
Consciousness or the experience of the
world outside of dichotomy that is what
we're doing so as I spiral rotate all
this stuff my dichotomous mind my ego
tripartite mind is going where are we
going what are we doing if you pay
attention how many times have you got
lost on when we're doing a lot of
spirals and a lot of circles can't stay
up you see it wants to put it everything
on the grid
pattern it's going to undo that
dominance of the ego tripartite mind
that egoic
Consciousness the egoic experience of
the world dichotomous experience of the
world is going to undo it because it
can't lock on to its ideal State boom we
are against each other I'm going this
way no I'm going this way you get it it
undoes it and now you undo Yin and
yangong you're pre Yin y State got it
this is bji or
D pre dichotomy okay God undescribable
unknowable got it that's where you're at
hence the god bind okay so that's what
we're trying to do so trying to
intellectually understand what we're
doing is stopping you from doing it okay
well what do I do instead you just do
the
practices just do the practices don't
try to understand it's trying to
understand it is going to keep the egoic
mind functioning and this
is something that is to be felt
something that is to be
experienced so it's not just that it's
beyond dichotomy and therefore Beyond
language and therefore Beyond describe
describ ability it's not just that it's
that the very function
of the Mind the part of us the
Consciousness that part of us that
thinks in dichotomy that could put it in
symbolic form that could make a language
of it cannot experience what we're
trying to experience and hence all the
practices about mushin you see you're
you're trying to you're trying to do the
no mind what they're talking about is
what I have summed up for you in an
expedited fashion is that functioning of
that experience of the world that mind
that's what we want to bring us stop to
okay so likewise if you're
here and you're thinking
self-defense got it you're going to
activate that egoic mind and you're
never going to know what we're doing
okay now here's the weird
part while I say Kon waza is not
self-defense I say there're these
alchemical rituals of purification which
is a return to a pre yinong State
okay while they're not
self-defense because it is a yinong
culture it is also a concentric culture
so if you can't enter into this
state
you also can't be
Marshall okay so for example when I
showed the hand grab it's like that's
not Marshall you see but a lot of people
thinking is cuz I'm grabbing it and I'm
flexing do you get
it even though my goal is not to be
unlockable over that's not my goal if I
am knock over I'm not Marshall do you do
you understand that okay
so these are what they are but if you do
want to be
Marshall with Japanese
Jiu-Jitsu you have to be able to do
these drills you have to be able to do
these purification rituals if you can't
I don't you're not Marshall I'm sorry
you're not you have to be bigger and
stronger than your opponent and May and
they have to be on arm and you have to
be armed maybe have a chance
okay